Let's think about what we've learned. Now, we know that a function has the same
number of zeros, and the some number of linear factors as its degree. And, of
course, we need to make sure that we count the repeats here. We've also seen
that complex zeros always come in pairs as conjugates. And we know how to find
zeros of all different types. I think it's time then, to work through an
example that involves multiple techniques we've learned. This is going to be a
great problem to help you summarize all the important aspects of determining
zeros. So, get ready for this amazing polynomial function. We have f of x
equals, we're off to a pretty good start. 2x to the fourth, minus 13x cubed,
plus 32x squared, minus 13x, and that's it. I hope you're impressed. So, if we
want to find the zeros of this function, how do you think the best way to start
would be? Should we factor the first two terms and then factor the last two
terms? Should we grab a snack, since it's going to be a long ride? Should we
pull out the greatest common factor from all of the terms? Should we use the
rational zero theorem involving negative 13 and 2? Should we divide both sides
by x? Or should we combine like terms?